Con quan mục bộ tăng bệnh năng kia khu trăm hành lâm, tông tin từ bệnh tự bệnh sản yên bình đơn vị vừa sử gií,
tính hành cập cứu đữ bệnh nghiệm một táng tuổi bị ngộ độc xai thuốc phía.
Tha thông tin từ ra đình, bệnh có bệnh việt khó chiệu, quay khóc, đi ngoài phần lòng nhiều lần, để khoảng 18 giờ của ngày.
Giờ đình đã tự ý pha ló xai thuốc phía cho bệnh ủng, một bài thuốc xa dành trình miệng giúp trẻ giám tuy trẻ.
Sau khi sự dụng bệnh quay khóc nhiều hơn, sau đó mệt là phần sạch game, thở nất ra đình phải đưa bệnh đi cấp cứu.
Qua thông khám và khai tháng tin sự, các bác sĩ trình đoàn bệnh bị mộ độc thu phíanh cành theo dưới lạc tiêu á.
Mày mắn, bê đa được đưa để bệnh viện kiệt thời, sau khi được sự chi cấp cứu,
dùng thuốc sẽ được đặc hiệu và thơ sóa sát tình trạm bê đã dần u立.
Bệnh nghi là trẻ xin đủ tháng, cân nặng lúc xin ba về một kêu gà, đã được tiêu phòng bệnh đủ,
hệ tại nặng bố kêu gà, bếng hoàn toàn quay mạnh, không có tin sự bệnh li hài dị ứng thuốc.
Theo các bác sĩ, chờ chứng lâm sàng gió giá nhất khi bị hộ độc xai tuy phy là biểu hiện dạm tình số thơ,
thở chậc có thể tin trên đứng gần thơ, đồng tự con nhỏ.
Một số biểu hiện khác có thể sẽ ra như mề sàng, tụi thích á, như tin chậc, hà như độc cơ thể,
bếnh nhân từ vong chủ yếu gió tình trạm thiếu o ci.
Tự chứ hợp trên, các bác sĩ mình định sản như ninh bình cành báo,
bếng sự giúp các mẹ sân dân hoặc thúc nằm không só thình phần cho chẻ là vô cố vuy nghiệm.
Đây là những quan nhận chưa có cân tự khó và có thể để lại những hộ quà tiêu cực đếng giúp hệ của chè,
thậm xí vây từ vong.